[Music]
on march 26
2018 a passenger train leaves pyongyang
north korea
21 bulletproof cars painted an olive
drab lumber across the countryside
then over the chinese border
rumors begin throughout the
international community
this is the official train of the north
korea leadership
used by kim il-sung and kim jong-il
the grandfather and father of current
leader
kim jong-un
no one outside of the notoriously
secretive nation
knows who is aboard some speculate it is
kim yo-jong
un's younger sister and most trusted
advisor
it is not until the train reaches its
final destination
beijing that it is revealed kim jong-un
the 34-year-old dictator himself is the
passenger
in the months preceding this meeting
what follows in beijing
and in the months to come are the
preliminary steps
to what may be the most important
diplomatic event of our young century
a path to peace on the korean peninsula
and a way to bring the north koreans
into the international fold
after 70 years of isolation
[Music]
but the path to peace will be one of
twists and turns
as allies and the u.s jockey for
position
to protect their interests and maintain
security
by the time president donald trump and
chairman kim jong-un meet face-to-face
in singapore
it is still unclear what each party
wants
or will be willing to do
this is the great game
[Music]
north korea remains an enigma
and only those who have sat across the
table with north korean negotiators
understand the challenges i do believe
that
they're very tough they're very well
prepared they read
everything uh especially media
what makes them so tough uh it's not
just their culture but the fact that
they have been
isolated they've been sanctioned they
hardly any of them the
citizens leave north korea
they have television that's programmed
every evening
for three hours the government tells you
what you're gonna see
and inevitably they hate the united
states
at the end of the day diplomacy is
really
trying to get the other side to do
something they don't really want to do
dealing with another country make it
clear that you make the hard choices
today
and i'm not promising you the end of
hard choices
but i'm promising you that in the future
you won't have to make them alone
mostly i don't see it as a gift you
usually use diplomacy more
with your adversaries than with your
friends
and so it is this matter of being
prepared
and putting yourself into the other
country's shoes
and figuring out what you do
in order to solve the problem
and it's not a gift it is how you talk
to those you disagree with
the democratic people's republic of
korea
dprk is anything but democratic
from the ashes of world war ii loomed
the first
post-war spread of soviet communism
in august 1945 the korean peninsula
and her people were effectively divided
at the 38th parallel
an arbitrary divide
using a national geographic map the
future u.s secretary of state
dean rusk and fellow army staffer
colonel charles tick bone steel knew the
decision of the 38th parallel
made no economic or geographic sense
but with the cold war about to cast a
long shadow
the united states wanted seoul and the
democratic leaning south
under their alliance
[Music]
kim il-sung the young charismatic rebel
famous for his insurrection against the
brutal decades-old japanese occupation
vied for power and shaped this new
republic
in the stalinist fashion adopting
a totalitarian reign of terror
kim solidified his place in the soviet
back north
then sought to unify the peninsula by
invading the south
and starting the korean conflict on june
25th
1950. in an air of renewed optimism
three years later a ceasefire was
reached
north korea a nation established by
warfare
will be perpetuated by self-imposed
isolation
bloodshed and humanitarian horrors
it's the most unique country in the
world what other country in the world is
confucian communist hereditary
dynasty there's no country like this
while it also commits human rights
violations
the united nations commission of inquiry
said there's no other parallel
in contemporary history except nazi
germany and this is north korea
i don't think there's another country
that's more isolated than north korea
[Applause]
so truly a unique place
and they have been challenging american
policy for nearly 70 years
i think any political question has to
start with a map
and when you look at a map of northeast
asia it's a pretty compact
area and you're seeing russian far east
interests
right there you're seeing japan right
there china
enormous interest right there south
korea then in the middle of this
you have this funny little thing called
north korea
and so how does it affect the countries
around it and i would say it affects
them all big time
north koreans figured out how to work
united states so
there's usually a provocation of some
sort whether it's a missile test or a
nuke test
and then there's international
condemnation that follows
and then they sort of up the end like a
poco game oh yeah here's more
and then sort of we have a collective uh
oh no and then they step back and say
okay
and they here's what we can do they they
have some sort of charm offensive peace
offensive then we meet with them we
negotiate we give them aid
some rewards some time passes then back
to provocation
so sort of get you know provoke and get
paid cycle
for generations the north korean people
have been controlled by a police state
that has perfected propaganda to an art
their belief in the kim family dynasty
is absolute devotion
information is tightly controlled by the
korean central news agency
the kcna established in 1946.
there's obviously been many other deeply
repressive
communist dictators stalin now they
didn't have
the technology that the kim family had
they didn't have the degree of social
control so they didn't have
speakers in every village speakers on
the wall of every home to control people
they didn't have
television in every home they didn't
even have these
portraits of the leaders
it's kind of a religious cult
it's the deity it's the leaders the
grandfather
the father now kim jong-un that are not
just
political figures they're godlike
religious figures
and what they say determines how north
koreans act
kim jong-un only had a very short amount
of time
to build his legitimacy within the
regime kim jong-il by
comparison had 30 years to create his
his legitimacy kim jong-un had none of
this
but a lot of things very interesting
things began to happen when kim jong-un
came to power
the first thing that happened is they
had the missile test which was a failure
but what does north korea do they admit
it was a failure
unprecedented why did they do that gave
people pause
to think that maybe this was something
different kim jong-un laid down the
rosetta stone
of where he wanted to take this regime
people would no longer have to tighten
their belts
this was an important statement by kim
jong-un there was
no mention whatsoever of the nuclear
program
in that speech because that's not where
kim jong-un
wanted his legacy that was kim jong-il's
legacy was the nuclear program
his legacy was to create the strong and
prosperous nation
he then created a kind of chaotic
situation
within the uh workers party the north
korean workers party
and actually had his uncle chung song
tech
perp walked out of a party meeting and
killed the next day
so kim jong-un began a series of
executions
of senior north korean figures
such that it's it was hard to find a
common denominator
of why these people had been executed
but certainly
one can speculate that he didn't feel
they were sufficiently loyal to him
he purges over 400 senior military and
ministry leaders publicly
and allegedly has his older half-brother
murdered in a malaysian airport
poisoned by unwitting assassins
but he needs something else to secure
the kim dynasty
nuclear weapons that could pose a real
and present danger
to america and her asian allies
this would be the launching of the kim
jong-un era
he had to show legitimacy and if he
couldn't show legitimacy
on the economic realm he had to show
legitimacy in the security realm
and so he began to move very quickly
toward developing the nuclear program so
that he would have something to hang his
hat on
so it will give him a much stronger
position in which to negotiate with the
united states
kim jong-il moved the nuclear program
forward
in spite of international outcry and
on-again off-again treaties
[Music]
now it is his son who may finish the job
having a strong hand to negotiate a way
for his impoverished nation
to have an economic revival
i think that he does have a good hand to
play i mean he has in fact
um for you know from his perspective
developed a nuclear
potential and missiles to do the
delivery on it and he's managed to scare
the whole region into doing something
through 2016 to mid-september 2017
kim jong-un conducts three nuclear tests
including a hydrogen bomb and 30
short and long-range missile launches
including
intercontinental ballistic missiles
kim claims that they have nuclear
warheads small enough to fit on each
icbm
in 70 years in september 2017
president donald trump addresses the un
general assembly
no one has shown more contempt for other
nations and for the well-being of their
own people
than the depraved regime in north korea
he delivers a fiery speech attacking kim
jong-un
and threatening the destruction of his
country
rocket man is on a suicide mission for
himself
and for his regime trump's rhetoric
feeds directly into the north's
propaganda machine
that america wants to annihilate north
korea
i think that was definitely off script i
can't possibly imagine
administration officials like mattis or
secretary tillerson advocating totally
destroying north korea
i just can't possibly fathom that so i
think that was
president trump speaking i think north
korean officials have played a weak hand
just brilliantly while
i think the u.s approach has to some
degree backfired
essentially the u.s i think was trying
to intimidate
north korea with some of this rhetoric
about fire and fury
about complete destruction and i think
what we actually accomplished was that
we terrified south korea
into engaging in diplomacy with north
korea
i think that it's very hard to
really assess what effect president
trump's
language had on kim jong-un i don't know
whether it scared the japanese too
the united nations security council
votes for maximum pressure
through economic sanctions against the
north we have kicked the can down the
road long enough
there is no more road left a war of
words between pyongyang and president
trump
begins north korea best not
make any more threats to the united
states
kim refers to trump as a mentally
deranged dotard
[Music]
trump insists his red button is bigger
than kim's
still the dprk tests another icbm
this one experts agree has a range that
could hit the continental united states
the u.s talked openly about a bloody
nose military strike
that would [ __ ] nuclear testing sites
only a handful of experts believed this
was a viable solution
diplomacy is a hugely inefficient
toolbox it doesn't work very well
but in cases like north korea it's all
we have
to resolve this crisis ever since 1969
when north korea shot down a u.s
aircraft and
killed a bunch of americans the u.s has
looked for ways to
shape north korean behavior so
repeatedly you have very smart officials
who when they're out of power
they talk about military options
and then once in power and they look at
the
predictions of perhaps a million people
dying on the very first day
of a war with north korea then
they think well okay maybe this isn't
the best
option and they look at what's left and
what's left is diplomacy
adding to the growing anxiety on the
peninsula south korea was preparing the
2018
olympic games and there was precedent to
feel insecure
thirty years earlier in 1988 south
korea's first olympics were being
planned
the supreme leader kim il-sung set out
to create a chaotic atmosphere
to keep people away from the games
investigators now believe that a bomb
possibly planted by two passengers may
have caused sunday's crash of a korean
airliner
they downed a civilian airliner killed
115 people on board
it was a major terror attack that was
the reason why the united states put
north korea in the state sponsor of
terrorists
and it also shows you just the brutality
and just the insanity uh because
they downed a civilian airliner killing
115 people on board
just to disrupt the olympics that was
going to be
held in south korea
the dprk was banned from competition
but the games went on a huge coming out
party
a turning point for seoul as it pulled
further away from the north politically
economically and culturally
it only fueled the rivalry between the
two koreas
then on new year's day 2018
kim jong-un gives a speech as tensions
on the korean peninsula
reach a searing point
[Music]
at first i think there was a
considerable or
preponderance of views to the effect
that this is all an effort to create
wedges between the united states and
south korea
it's also an effort really to show south
korea
that north korea can be a good neighbor
even if it has nuclear weapons
this olive branch was heard around the
world
moon jae-in invites the north to march
together
at the gates i can understand what
president moon is trying to do now
in terms of they are living there in
this very dangerous area
and these issues and they're much more
complicated than just one issue like
missiles it's a
their way of life
the north korean delegation arrived at
the olympic games
led by kim's younger sister and closest
confidante
kim yo-jong
presence captivated the south koreans
part curiosity
part relief that she appeared so poised
and confident
north koreans won on that whole image
makeover contest
kim yo-jong was called ivanka of the kim
administration she was hugely popular in
south korea
she seemed human she seemed normal she
was charming she was smiling
we'll be telling the truth about north
korea at every stop
the american delegation led by vice
president pence
held talks with the north korean
defectors implored the south to ignore
overtures from the north met with the
family of otto warmbier
the university of virginia student who
died soon after being released from a
north korean prison in a coma
and avoided a state dinner so not to be
with a dprk delegation
during the opening ceremonies the body
language could not be more evident
as pen sat stone faced then when the
joint team
walked in it's not only north korean
olympians there were south korean
olympians that were walking in
you can stand up you can stand up and
cheer because
it's your ally your south korea is
hosting the olympics and you're seeing
the south korean athletes also coming in
with the north korean athletes so you
should stand up and be welcoming
i didn't think we scored any kind of
points on that image front
it's on this visit that kim yo-jong hand
delivers a letter from her brother
inviting president moon to meet him in
person
washington watches president moon as
somebody that
is regarded more as a liberal within
their system
had come forward with the idea that
there needed to be
more um cooperation
i also do think that um
there are those uh who believe in the
crazy man theory
that some of the threats that president
trump made
uh i think it's conceivable had some
role in
changing the mind of the north koreans
but i think the question is
what happens next
both washington and seoul agreed to keep
up the diplomatic momentum that began
since the new year
and president moon jae-in sends a
10-member delegation to pyongyang
kim jong-un calls the four-hour meeting
an open-hearted talk
actively improving the north-south
relations
and ensuring peace and stability on the
korean peninsula
washington remains skeptical saying that
the south should not normalize relations
with the north
without discussion of denuclearization
we remain determined to achieve
a denuclearization of the korean
peninsula
but president moon like a matchmaker
persuades the north and the u.s
to soften their positions insisting that
the two initiatives move in parallel
urging the u.s to start talks with the
dprk
kim jong-un says he will put
denuclearization of the peninsula
on the table and
three days later moon's diplomats are at
the white house
carrying a letter from chairman kim
president trump
appreciated the briefing and said
he would meet kim jong-un by may
to achieve permanent denuclearization
the first time a sitting american
president will meet face to face with
the leader of north korea
of the korean peninsula many in the
diplomatic community
are surprised enough and concerned
an unconventional president meeting an
unpredictable dictator
as equals a president known more for
behaving on
instinct than precedent who shuns
preparation or study
speaking directly with a famously
thin-skinned impulsive dictator
all while the white house is embroiled
in multiple scandals
a growing global trade war and the u.s
state department and national security
team
are in flux secretary of state rex
tillerson
is soon fired by trump national security
adviser h.r mcmaster
resigns afterward the issue is
how prepared president trump will be for
it usually
a um summit meeting takes place towards
the
end of negotiations where the president
can then come in and kind of
put the last stone in and really
add some peace to it but not having done
kind of the building of the whole thing
and so it will take incredible
discipline
if it fails if one of them walks out in
a huff
if one of them suggests no we can't do
this then where are you going to go
because you've already put in your
closer
and your closer your leaders should be
able to
kind of nail down the last two issues
that are out there
so instead you have your leaders uh
starting the process
i think they're both very much alike
they're autocratic they're unpredictable
and uh it could come out
a decent outcome but we're unsure
and i've said to the trump
administration the gamble of talking to
kim jong-un is a huge gamble but i think
it's the right gamble
but be prepared they're relentless if
we're not prepared
we don't have our act together we put up
unrealistic expectations they're going
to outsmart us
the wheels are literally in motion i've
seen that train
nobody else can ride in that drink the
good news is that he's starting to talk
to
other leaders
it's march 27th 2018. kim has not
traveled outside of the dprk
since he assumed power in 2011 and he
has yet to meet with another head of
state
they're going to china to ask for
something and and that's diplomacy
that's
you know you get squeezed you do
something and
and this is a rational actor
kim jong-un taking these steps
i believe i'm i'm not sure i'm not there
but this is what he's probably doing
one month before he meets with moon
chairman kim in a surprise move
arrives in beijing to meet president xi
jinping
for the first time i think he was do a
couple of things i think he was trying
to get
some sort of sanctions relief some sort
of see where china is
in all of that assured china that
china's interests would be protected
but i think also took an opportunity to
sort of showcase himself as a leader
i think he you really use it to
normalize uh
his image as a normal leader of a normal
country
a modern leader of a modern nation here
he brought his very young attractive
wife
and other senior north korean officials
spent four days with
president xi and there's president xi
his wife
kim jong-un his attractive wife drinking
laughing talking
so it's just a great image makeover for
kim
and i think he was very smart to have
done that
japanese prime minister shinzo abe meets
with trump
to assure japan's interests are not in
peril
[Music]
president trump confirms that then cia
chief
mike pompeo met secretly with kim
jong-un
two weeks earlier on easter weekend
beginning the planning process of the
trump kim summit
he just left north korea had a great
meeting
with kim jong-un and got along with him
really well really great
pompeo is poised to become secretary of
state and hardliner
former u.n ambassador john bolton is
appointed national security advisor
one week before kim jong-un and moon
jae-in meet
north korea declares it will halt all
nuclear and long-range missile tests
and as kim shifts national focus to the
north's economy
he says he will shut down one of his
nuclear test sites
president trump tweets this is very good
news for north korea
and the world big progress
now on the table is the denuclearization
of the korean peninsula
and discussion of a peace treaty
officially ending the korean war
which concluded with only an armistice
ceasing 70 years of hostility
the pon moon jam truce village traverses
both north and south korea
inside the demilitarized zone along the
38th parallel
here president moon and chairman kim
meet for the first time
on april 27 2018.
kim becomes the first north korean
leader to ever set foot in the south
optics show a warm and congenial
burgeoning relationship
well it was really interesting to watch
kim jong-un in terms of body language
his voice how he was handling himself
he's nothing like his father was
actually wasn't
very big introvert and was not social
he looked like kimura's son to me his
grandfather
he was warm he was effusive he was
touchy-filly
almost affectionate he laughed
wholeheartedly
so he came across as actually a charming
person
a social person who can engage with
people laughing and joking so all of
that
was very interesting to to me as a
career watcher
the day-long summit ends with a pledge
to formally end the korean war
and a declaration to denuclearize the
korean peninsula
another date is set to start
negotiations in mid-may
but fast-moving events in the coming
months begin to raise the stakes
of whether a summit with kim and trump
will even happen
the next day trump holds a
campaign-style rally
in macomb county michigan well i spoke
to the president this morning
of south korea for a long time they just
had a very good meeting
he gives us tremendous credit he gives
us all the credit
one of the fake news groups this morning
[Applause]
now they were saying what do you think
president trump had to do with it i'll
tell you what like how about
everything
[Applause]
once the south koreans thought of donald
trump as much of a danger as kim jong-un
but now for months they have been
thanking trump
for making the start of a reconciliation
possible
some believe it's to appeal to his ego
and maintain the momentum of the talks
president moon tells his senior
secretaries
president trump should win the nobel
peace prize
what we need is only peace
there are a lot of leaders who i think
are playing trump
in terms of understanding that if they
flatter him
um that they make an impression the
nobel peace prize
well i just think that uh president moon
was very nice when he suggested it i
want to
i want to get peace the main thing we
want to get peace north korean officials
start to take offense
that the president is taking all the
credit to help bring peace to the region
they claim the sanctions were not
responsible for kim coming to the
negotiating table
and washington is ruining the mood
leading up to the peace talks
it's not all just u.s maximum pressure
strategy
that led to this point i think kim
jong-un himself
had a strategy now he's get to sit down
with the president of the united states
for the first time it shows that kim
jong-un is a different kind of leader
he has shown himself to be bold and
astute and quite smart actually
i think then john bolton the new
national security adviser
who favors military action and regime
change with hostile nations
appears on cbs's face the nation the
requirement that kim jong-un agree to
give away those weapons before
you give any kind of concession i think
that's right i think we're looking at
the libya model of 2003
2004 we're also looking at what north
korea itself
has committed to previously north
koreans love to use libya as an example
of
why they must keep nuclear weapons they
repeatedly say
look what happened to gaddafi qaddafi
gave up nuclear weapons then the west
helped the revolt against gaddafi and
now qaddafi is dead
so when north korea is here john borton
said we're pursuing our libyan model
i think this is not helpful because
north korea's
are always they were afraid of becoming
another libya
secretary of state mike pompeo arrives
in pyongyang a second time
to discuss the summit
this time he returns with three
americans that were jailed in north
korea
for crimes against the state it's
believed to be a goodwill gesture by kim
and actually even before it becomes as
the us confers with anxious allies in
the region
kim too makes another surprise trip to
beijing
there's multiple and overlapping
interests and not all of them are
aligned this is very complicated
i speculate that kim jong-un was showing
xi jinping what a deal with united
states might look like and what does
china think of it
because you really need china's buy-in
meanwhile our ally japan is very unhappy
how things are unfolding even though
they can't really quite say it
because they are so worried that the
united states is going to make a deal
with north korea
that protects u.s interests south korea
is trying to be sort of honest broker
intermediary but it's sort of worried
that everything's going to blow up
so there's a lot going on with different
countries trying to seek their own
interests meanwhile president trump
fulfills a campaign promise
and pulls out of the iran nuclear deal
amid protests
by our european allies many speculate
what this would signal for the upcoming
summit with the dprk
it would be an interesting point of
conversation frankly
if kim jong-un said to president trump
we've looked at the iran deal and you
say it's the worst deal ever
why do you say it's the worst deal ever
because i'm not sure
we can reach a deal that's anywhere as
good
as the iran deal from your perspective
mr president
so i think the president is going to
have to
make some attitudinal changes about the
iran deal
in a way that will help if there is a
prospect of a north korean deal
wrinkles begin to appear as the dprk
starts reading into statements coming
out of washington
diplomacy is not twitter or facebook or
press releases or
cable news diplomacy is human beings
talking to each other and reaching an
agreement
showing respect showing respect for
culture
letting the other side save face letting
the other side
save credit building relationships
that's diplomacy
the north releases a statement rejecting
bolton's libya model
claim referring to him as repugnant
they say they will never completely
disarm
that combined with a joint south korean
and american military exercise
along the border of the north is enough
for the north to cancel the next
inter-korean talks
and puts the trump kim summit at risk
thank you to save his summit with kim
president trump
begins to backpedal on bolton's
statement well the libyan model
isn't a model that we have at all when
we're thinking of north korea
but if we make a deal i think kim
jong-un is going to be
very very happy i really believe he's
going to be very happy but this is just
the opposite
and i think when john bolton made that
statement
he was talking about if we're going to
be having a problem
because we cannot let that country
have nukes we just can't do it
with three weeks to the historic summit
set for june 12
2018 in singapore the tension once again
rises
and president moon makes a trip to
washington in the hope he can save the
talks
to north korean experts this is no
surprise
the idea of kim giving up his nuclear
arsenal wholesale
in exchange for economic relief was
always a non-starter
they want their own security assured
they'll look for some sort of security
agreement quite possibly
asking us not to have any more exercises
with the south koreans
potentially they could ask us to remove
troops
or potentially they could ask us to
reduce our nuclear
arsenal after meeting with moon
trump says he can live with a slower
path to denuclearization
reversing his earlier demand for
immediate disarmament
it is now that events begin at a frantic
pace
the south korean leadership predicts a
99.9 percent chance of the summit
continuing
but the north picks up on statements
made by vice president pence
you know there was some talk about the
libyan mind last week
and um you know as the president made
clear
um you know this uh this will only
end like the libyan model ended if kim
jong-un doesn't make a deal some people
saw that as a threat
well i i think it's more of a fact
the north koreans had only harsh words
calling the vice president
a political dummy and continued
whether the u.s will meet us at a
meeting room or encounter us at nuclear
to nuclear showdown
is entirely dependent upon the decision
of the u.s
the nuclear program is intimately tied
into two primary objectives
for kim jong-un and the north korean
regime one
is the survival of the regime and two is
the perpetuation of the kim family rule
and the nuclear program is intimately
tied into that
the next morning trump blindsides the
two koreas
and abruptly cancels the summit
expressing
tremendous anger and open hostility on
north korea's part
but he leaves the door open to future
talks
i believe that this is a tremendous
setback
for north korea and indeed a setback for
the world
two days later chairman kim and
president moon meet at the truce village
they agree to hold frequent discussions
as the clock ticks american and north
korean officials
hold back channel meetings the north
openly states they are willing to
continue with the summit
president trump thanks chairman kim for
a solid response to his letter
and says the white house is preparing
for talks on june 12th
president trump tweets we have put a
great team together
for our talks with north korea meetings
are currently taking place concerning
summit and more
there's no way to describe to um
anybody how long it takes to have these
kind of talks and how much preparation
has to come from it and also what the
relationship
is with the allied countries
[Music]
now an event that would normally take
months or years to arrange
is happening in days mike pompeo meets
in new york city to discuss the path to
denuclearization
with vice chairman kim yong-chol the
dprk's top
nuclear negotiator and in pyongyang
kim meets with russia's foreign minister
with an invitation to come to moscow
raising concerns with the white house
president trump tweets our united states
team has arrived in north korea
to make arrangements for the summit
between kim jong-un and myself
i truly believe north korea has
brilliant potential
it has been incredibly frustrating and
north korea has
lied to us has cheated us we indeed have
likewise not fulfilled some of our
obligations
to north korea but
the last best hope of trying to resolve
some of these issues
is going to be to rely on diplomacy
there's no other way there's no
alternative to try to resolve this
crisis except to try to negotiate a
better one
after talks with pompeo kim yong-chol
arrives at the white house
carrying a letter from kim jong-un
the first time a north korean dignitary
visited there
since 2000 after two hours
president trump and vice chairman kim
yong-chol
emerged from the white house you people
are gonna have to travel because you'll
be in singapore on june 12th
and i think it'll be a process it's not
i never said it goes in one meeting i
think it's going to be a process
but the relationships are building and
that's a very positive thing
two weeks later after a bruising g7
summit
trump is accused of further alienating
traditional allies
he leaves for singapore confident that
he can forge a new relationship
with a traditional adversary insisting
he doesn't need a lot of preparation
the whole concern about the summit was
the idea that they were essentially
going to do it with very little
preparation
and the president was going to trust his
instincts
that's one problem the second problem is
sometimes his instincts are wrong
and so uh that's where you need to have
a lot of preparation
so they essentially went in with very
little preparation and they certainly
didn't have any
agreement on the overall issue of
denuclearization
except that north korea said they're in
favor of it
in singapore a media frenzy begins as
over 2 500 reporters gather
chairman kim arrives aboard a chinese
state airliner
some say it's a message from xi jinping
that the dprk is his vassal
tread lightly
the prime minister of singapore meets
with kim
and everywhere he travels he's treated
with rock star status
an international pariah now looked upon
as a statesman
who may bring peace to a nervous region
[Music]
president trump arrives on air force one
after a state lunch he remains in his
hotel for the night
the president is fully prepared for the
meeting tomorrow i have personally had
the opportunity to make sure
that he's had a chance to hear lots of
different voices um
all of the attendant opportunities and
risks and that we have we have put
put these two leaders in the right place
in stark contrast kim seemingly relishes
the attention
as he tours the streets of the city
next morning june 12th the flag-draped
stage is set
for the historic handshake as the two
leaders meet at 904 am
for the first time
they will speak one-on-one with only
interpreters in the room
for 45 minutes probably the thing i
worried about the most was when he was
going in
one on one because he's not terribly
well rooted in some of the issues and i
thought maybe he'd get spun around on
that
and we still don't know what he what he
agreed to
be successful
after a working lunch the two emerged to
address an anxious global community
[Music]
pretty comprehensive document and we've
had a
really great term together a great
[Music]
relationship
the analysis is that though the meeting
was historic
the details of the agreement were vague
at best
trump spent much time flattering kim
elevated him to status of an equal and
in a move that blindsided south korea
japan and the pentagon trump agreed to
halt u.s
led military exercises on the peninsula
potentially weakening any military
response
what was signed was a an agreed
statement
but when you read the text of the agreed
statement there's a lot less there
than meets the eye certainly less
than was agreed back in 2005. i think
they're going to need another statement
or better yet maybe ignore
what was done in singapore and just
start building something
as the secretary of state begins the
very necessary diplomacy
the hard work of keeping the north
engaged begins
and it could draw out well beyond the
trump administration date of 2020
[Music]
but for now the threat of war has been
hushed
this problem is not going to be solved
with just the us and north korea
we need to be talking to the chinese we
need to be talking to the south koreans
and of course we need to be talking to
the japanese as well
[Music]
you